the effort to push conservatives  out to the margins to demonize and  stigmatize us uh these efforts have  reached a new level in recent weeks and  this is not something we should take for  granted or just passively accept on the  grounds that it's inevitable a few weeks  weeks ago we were being labeled as  literal terrorists for talking about the  medical procedures children's hospitals  are inflicting on kids just to talk  about it is terrorism  and then as you know the president  united states appears in ominous red  lighting to warn that uh people who  disagree with him politically are  dangerous extremists and threats to our  very way of life our democratic system  and now we have a major event organizing  website that has declared a hit film  hate speech and banned it from its  platform without further explanation